لا لا الاشخاص الاسعد هم القادرون على
تحديد الوقت المناسب للمضي قدما في منهم
الحمد لله هذه نصيحه مشاهدينا تاتينا من
طبيب امري
كيه وقرنا من الزمن وهي تكشف سر الحياه
الصحيه السعيده
الطبيب
مجاري هي البالغه من العمر 100 وسنتين فقط
كشفت في كتابها ان عقودا من الخبرات
تعلمتها دروسا لحياه صحيه وسعيده وكذلك
هادفه اوضحت ايضا ان العاده التي جعلتها
تمتلك حياه صحيه وسعيده هي التخلص من
الضغوطات والقدره على الاستثمار باشياء
مفيده مثل العلاقات والحياه المهنيه لفتت
الى ان الاشخاص الاسعد هم القادرون على
عدم التمسك بامور قد تشعرهم
بالضغط النفسي
طنش تعش تنفعش
بدنا نتخلص من كل الضغوطات ونضلنا هيك حسن
المنيع بدون ما نتاثر باي شيء صعبه صعبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات